[Music]
THQ Nordic and vigil games announced
Darksiders 3 IG n first they had more
details on it and I'm pretty excited
about this Darksiders 1 & 2 I really
liked Darksiders vigil games emerge kind
of doing a Zelda clone for lack of a
better term deal with war one of the
four horsemen and then Darksiders 2 came
out and you were def going through an
open-world kind of puzzle environmental
puzzle platforming heavy kind of hack
and slash adventure and now dark times 3
you are fury the sister to the four
horsemen and we kind of want to talk
about what we wanted Darksiders 3 I
think I'm probably the biggest
Darksiders fan in the office so I guess
I'll start but just to preface it so
fury is going to be more of a whip based
character so people on Twitter we're
asking a second mmm she's the sister of
the four horsemen is she not a horse
woman I don't know uh asking the real
would imagine uh but we did have a
question uh poison ivy the audios on
John Luke is rolling this with the audio
we could watch this if we want we could
but keep going uh yeah so Fury's gonna
be almost like a Bayonetta thing kind of
like whips and more you know like fluid
kind of combat and almost like God of
War even with Kratos and his blades of
chaos but here you see the elder charred
council if I recall correctly but here's
fury herself and you see war kind of
chained up right here from the first
game but yeah she'll be she's more mage
based based on the news she will be kind
of transforming into different forms
making use of those maybe elemental
powers you can see her here in terms of
what we want this trailer doesn't show
much so John Luke you could probably
actually like cut it here in terms of
what we want I want to see them actually
kinda expanded because Darksiders one
was pretty small and confined compared
to Darksiders to Darksiders to they
actually give you this open-world to
travel through they there were many more
like incidental side bosses here you see
her talking to the Smith from Darksiders
to
I think that's him it looks like a very
exciting conversation at the yeah
they're pretty into it so here we are
yeah and we will essentially be it'll be
more of an open world of course but it's
also cool that it's david adams who
worked on the original game at Joe
Madureira David Adams actually recently
worked on Chronos really good VR game
Pete you liked it I liked Chronos a hell
of a lot so yeah I heard good things
about that so they know what they're
doing in terms of 3d action-adventure
kind of stuff Chronos was a pretty good
example of that but same with Darksiders
one too so it's kind of people
Darksiders to had a bunch of new people
on it but uh then the THQ dissolution
happened and Darksiders kind of fell off
the face of the earth for a while but
they were almost like cult classics and
people kept asking for a sequel and now
this gonna be THQ Nordics first game and
gunfire games will be working on this
but they are kind of focused more on
like an open-world it says she's
tracking down the seven deadly sins as
the bosses that was kind of a thing the
bosses in Dark Side one and two were
like you know like more typical Zelda
kind of scale bosses so I'm curious to
see I would like to see them kind of
form the world around those seven deadly
sins so maybe you go into the area with
fighting lust and it's a lot different
than gluttony and whatnot if you've seen
her that movie se7en know if you've seen
seven with Brad Pitt and Morgan Freeman
then maybe you know what to expect but
uh yeah people keep making comparisons
to what's the character's name from
Bayonetta no huh that's not Bayonetta um
I know this is not it's not coming to me
no I don't have it no okay but anyway
people are making comparisons to kind of
platinum style action just because she
has a whip but I mean I thought the
action when two was good it was more
scythe based I would like to see them
actually kind of figure out new ways to
incorporate her powers into the Trevor
inta like environmental puzzles because
two environmental puzzles
we're cool at first death would have
this really slick traversal while
running and everything kind of got stale
toward the end the game and I don't
think they kind of incorporated the
puzzles themselves into the open-world
as much as they could
Zelda games the older Zelda games is
easier to do that because they're these
actually streamlined dungeons where
could do that but I want to see them
integrate puzzle into the open world
more organically that makes sense
especially I'm wondering if the her like
elemental powers will extend past combat
and into that kind of travel and whatnot
I don't know what do you guys from what
you know of doctor everyone - I think
you all have like brief experience them
what are you kind of hoping for with
Darksiders 3 in regards to like people
from Chronos coming back or people that
you know worked on VR games and came
back you think they could have learned
anything from Chronos your time with
Chronos
that you would like to see implemented
here I mean to be honest to do it the
what I've played of the first two games
I didn't have any problems with it like
I kind of would just like more of the
same and I do like how this story does
jump around between the first two so to
kind of culminate here I think that's
really cool like I I rarely say this but
I just want more of the same mm-hmm I
know it's really safe answer but it's
kind of true
well yeah cuz people a lot of people
were hoping that there would be like a
co-op game with all four horsemen but
I'm kind of glad that they're sticking
to the third-person action in terms of
bringing a new character into it and I'm
I don't know I'm curious how the whip
will work castlevania lords of Shadow
was a 3d xbox360 outing with a also ps3
MPC right a ps3 pc that generation and
he used a whip and that was actually
really satisfying combat it's kind of
like like I said Kratos the blade to
chaos almost like that reach right same
sort of momentum yeah I don't know from
like in terms of fighting these seven
bosses and kind of navigate this over
worlds or anything you hope to see from
it because this is your kind of game Rob
like in terms of I'm sure like gauge I
mean I really not familiar the series
you've been playing near though like
that's a third-person action right
that's what I was immediately like
trying to like make those like poles
right like oh that's that seems pretty
fun like I was walking some of the
combat it looks great for two but I
guess opposed like the open-world you
know that is such a heavy-handed
I mean what is this over open-world
gonna be like right like is it going to
be even enjoyable compared to like I
feel like what has happened with like
horizon and Zelda yeah because
Darksiders 2 was more of a item gated
open-world
rise of the Tomb Raider Metroidvania ich
would you like to see that Kelly or more
of a open word Rob or just one you can
explore yeah like I mean I just if hope
there's a reason for the open world is
what I'm trying to say like I yeah I'd
like nor more open world games I play I
have to be entertained throughout right
like like that's why Zelda was so great
they're a dime it doesn't know right um
well yeah it's just like if they're done
wrong it's really really boring so there
has to be something some draw to it
obviously this trailer didn't really
give a whole lot of information so I
don't need to know more I really like C
I really like seven deadly sins is a
theme though that's like totally my jam
so it's pretty clear structure right up
front you know who you're gonna be
fighting exactly and to be really I'm
assuming they were pretty good with
their bosses and Darksiders - especially
pretty massive scale kind of reminds me
of got a war - opens up with that
Colossus II fight right away or three
when you're fighting uh but the Titans
on uh Poseidon you're pretty close after
because God of War is another comparison
people make with these games kind of
because of the combat and the fact that
when you acquire a new weapon it kind of
you can switch between em on the fly
like it's blades of chaos blade of
Artemis Artemis sword and god of war and
I've played those in a while but in the
sense that God of War three are hunting
down uh the gods of Olympus taking about
one by one I that'd be pretty cool to
see how the story integrates the seven
deadly sins as bosses seems pretty like
metaphysical in terms of that's the
seven bosses you're hunting down
interesting if having to confront those
sins somehow did something to you as a
character mm-hmm like you have to become
a worse version of yourself to actually
gain power mm-hmm
or resist Lenny was just stuff from stay
strong now yeah yeah but unfortunately
details are pretty sparse on this game
so far
IGN has the there IGN first which is
like a month long coverage of game
releases Alma okay usually um so I know
a lot of Pearce is heading it up so she
has gameplay impressions and stuff cool
but don't go to IGN just wait until we
hear the news from them and put it on
GameSpot anyway um yeah but I'll let us
know what you think there were questions
on Darksiders 3 on
Twitter but I think we kind of answered
them I don't know people are wondering
how the progression is gonna go i fits
anything like Darksiders to you'll that
was currency based and then you come
back to like one person in the hub would
be who you buy abilities from like new
like like I said that that's where the
God of War comes and you would kind of
be buying this new sword attack this new
jumping smash attack new earthquake
around you attack so I'm really curious
to see how the hub world will function
if there is one in progressing fury
skills because she sounds super
interesting she's more mage base uh war
and the first game is kind of a brute
close combat really a more strength base
like grappling and stuff to death was
really acrobatic and kind of air
juggling more that kind of style but I'm
curious see how fury will factor in it
with the whip and elemental powers but
yeah if any questions the chat or if
you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot after let us know what you want
let us know what you think they need to
do to get you back interest is the
interest in this series after such a
long hiatus or if you're just excited
for it anyway
[Music]